salut à tous alors aujourd'hui retour au
spot des criminels où on a trouvé des
cadres de moto un ordinateur volé des
armes des munitions une mobylette
alors il ya alex qui me rejoint on va
sûrement encore sortir du très lourd ici
c'est parti pour la pêche c'est une
sorte de manivelle ouais sommes pas j'ai
décroché sur comment ça va jésus bravo à
eux machin c'est quoi ça un petit leurs
tentes et ben stiller et un burin c'est
mieux refroidir est lourd à une belle
pièce seule pièce de bagnols
bah ça va une fois de leurs bases et
sarah quand même en bas du coffee shops
en balançait beaucoup
au plus tard est aussi une mère douce
est choqué c'est radio c'est clair que
c'est que à 8 ans et n'ont jamais fait
ça premier celui du virage que durera sa
rente pas assez encore dans la voiture
voilà ses bijoux fantaisie non ces
exemples on va pas trop mais le travail
ouais c'est sympa mais je peux dire que
c'est de loin le long si l'on pressent
bien
hu a lâché [ __ ] cette année encore
un cadre un cadre rempli de merde au
tour a été super lourdes pour le nombre
de tissu qui doit y avoir là dessous là
c'est répugnant tapis de voiture sans
vision le car c'est chez ba oui près de
bagnoles des années 70 quoi voiture ne
sais quoi de quoi sentenial hier je
regardais une vidéo lire le mec en
angleterre elle a sorti par envol à je
reviendrai
des arômes et bienvenue dans eyes un
cadre bien cadres alors bon ça c'est
cool c'est facile à transporter coupé en
dehors plus sur sympa franchement tout
ces tissus bon aucune idée si vous savez
en commentaire les gars pourquoi il ya
autant de tissu dans l'orb garde encore
ses cheveux ses inventeurs du scout
j'avais juste celui au compteur non 1077
abus la bloque disque avec alarme ah oui
c'est logique de motos à deux motos
d'accord y'a pas petite fortune 100 %
mâles ouest alors new wave et du couffo
une crise pour être comme ça on aurait
alors quatre cas où je pose de
télévision comme ses grands frères
[Musique]
à quelque chose ouais 2d juste en bas
coûts encore remplies j'ai fait tomber
des trucs tout à l'heure à salève et du
fils autour du fil de pêche non c'est
chrome et bien ce truc
la cdu comme celle de l'ue sellali c'est
vraiment bizarre ce truc table de la
lutte non tu veux plus value ah ouais
c'est lui parce que c'est de l'histoire
je n'avais pas de câbles d'aluminium
temps fait quoi toi volume ça tu sais
que c'est aux listes jamais jamais
jamais eu de cadeau d'adieu et en la
matière la plastique coton produits
plastiques renforcés si vous savez dans
les commentaires ce que ces ag eu le
truc avait échappé c'est sûr pour moi
c'est un outil a non seulement un
certain point tout ouais ouais ouais et
l'encourager et nichols a pour père
salins oh cool moi je garde
a vieux mange de tout aux petites
ampoules avec du cuivre ça fait plaisir
[Musique]
ouais donc qu'est ce donc pas une des
clés alors nous a échappé depuis tout ce
temps il est là depuis un moment
donc là on a cru voir un code est encore
un cadre là on va on va mettre à 10 ans
sur ce spot 1956 aux eaux
elle est super bien conservé c'est gros
comme un paysan vous aider l'italie
italia au oui les balles c'est les vols
accusent les han fait alors à temps
ouais ouais c est comme quoi c'est pas
vieux il y avait un sachet autour un
temps par le piccolo de selecta rentrent
sains car c'est plus blindés les gars
allez assez bon donc là il y en a une
belle ribambelle meilleur temps devant
sa relance est vrai qu il y en a qui
sont défoncées et que la balle
d'écologie modèle ouvert 24 sur 24 mais
je crois qu'un chargeur mais qu'un char
gens croient que c'est 30
oui oui on a plusieurs pour les
personnels à plusieurs mais charger bah
oui c'est ça c'est ça mais je te disant
trouver là thomson connais les mecs
l'entrée on va écouter de retour sur le
spot pour finir cette vidéo moi j'étais
pas là au début donc je viens m'amuser
d'autant plus que des abrutis en rejeter
la mobylette dans l'eau le jour 2 jours
top chrono en 2 jours
vous devrez peut-être vu la vidéo je
vous ai dit si on leur mettait dans
l'autre on va remonter à verser l'apa
lourd ça va le faire c'est un truc une
chance c'est que ce sera mauvais mais
voilà vous avez mouillé ma voiture vous
êtes content maintenant c'est pas grave
ça m'amuse moi oui
[Applaudissements]
voilà en trois minutes
bon c'est bon donc vous l'avez déjà vu
pour ceux qui n'ont pas vu vous pouvez
aller voir la vidéo
et voilà c'est toujours mais ils ont
bien fait de vouloir mettre dans l'eau
est toute propre maintenant je crois que
je peux la mettre dans mon salon ça noir
a de la gueule on va écouter c'est la
fin de cette petite partie de pêche
qu'est ce qu'on a pensé quand un chat a
pu vous allez même couleur alors sinon
voilà ça rigolait regarder on a tout
ramassé qui reste juste voir la petite
barrière de sécurité mais bon ce pas une
grande halle de la mairie la récupérera
sinon pour la ferraille